have another quote for you and it's just
a ton of quotes this one is from Maxwell
Maltz and it reads often the difference
between a successful man and a failure
is not one's better abilities or ideas
but the courage that one has to bet on
his ideas to take calculated risk and to
act
excuse me into act so do you relate to
that I can read it again if you want I
kind of put it I think it helps if the
idea is good to begin with you know
confident that we're talking about that
earlier I think confidence does help a
lot but if your idea is bad then being
persistent and and loud about it they're
going to get you that far either like I
like people a lot that are quieter and
have great ideas and I have to I know I
have to pay good attention because they
won't point out how great their ideas
are so I have to kind of listen because
I know the diamonds are in there and
they won't screen them into my face but
it's probably true that a lot of great
ideas just die because someone doesn't
have that feeling to project it to the
world or the persistent it's also hard
because the first couple of reactions
might be negative that you get to
something you know where you are
pitching it to someone and maybe the
pitch of how you describe the idea isn't
completely worked out here and you're
just trying it out and then you get
negative feedback and I could imagine
that that shuts a lot of people down I
think that's a very sensitive seeing
your audience for your unfinished ideas
is something that people maybe are not
as conscious about as they should be
that it's as if you are carrying it as
if you're giving someone a raw egg and
you kind of want to know that they will
be careful with that raw egg and not
just destroy because they don't get it
or because they they want their opinion
in there quicker there's also and test
screenings I think there are different
groups of people that one group of
people is always they won't tell you
what they think or you movie they will
tell you what movie they would have made
or wish you had made and you always want
to say like that's not the movie I made
you know so I think if you if you come
with an idea to that crowd then you will
get discouraged very soon but on the
other hand there is the danger of not
going out with an unfinished idea to a
test audience early enough and kind of
keeping it being very protective of it
and working on it and and not wanting to
expose it to the world until you feel
it's the best version of what it can be
and then when you show to the world they
will react to it and you'll go like how
damn I wish I'd heard that comment four
weeks ago when it was still flexible and
I could still do something with it now
it's so rigid and the whole thing will
fall apart if I integrate that idea that
I just heard from someone but back then
it would have changed everything so I
think over the years I have gone out to
people earlier and earlier and by now
with the very first idea and see how
they respond because it is it can change
so much and just to bounce people off of
ideas off of people I think is a huge
valuable tool and to know people well
enough to know in what ways they are
bouncing it back to you do you have to
put on the extrovert hat when you do
that being an introvert or being more
internal not necessarily the extrovert
ahead because I'm not a Salesman that
the idea can't sell itself in that
moment then it's probably not a good
idea but you definitely need a thick
skin like there's nothing I never feel
more humiliated and stepped in the back
then after a test screening but that's
what test screenings are for you know
you don't make a test if you don't
invite people to test screening just for
everyone to say like there was great
have a good day yeah you want them to
say I was bored I was offended that
didn't work that didn't work what the
hell were you thinking about them and to
hear that from 20 people whether they're
your best friends or strangers doesn't
matter it's always an emotional
catastrophe because I think a story you
put out your view of the world out there
no matter what that story is the way you
handle performances the way you
the editing rhythm the color scheme
everything about it always revealed
something about you as a person and how
you see the world so now you present
that and you are suddenly the raw egg
you know viewers so you don't have any
protection against that and everyone is
just bashing it you know and making you
feel like you are on the dumbest person
in the world they don't attend to them
they have the feeling they're very
sensitive and careful but of course what
you are here and you don't hear any of
the positive stuff you only hear what
it's me I only hear the negative stuff
so I'm never more depressed than the
night after a test screen but it always
is one of the most important steps that
Jessica the first one a catastrophe just
get through it it's like a traffic
accident and then test grading by test
screening it gets a little better a
little better a little better and I
think the the goal at first when I was
test grading my first movie I thought
the goal was to make all negative
comments go away like I know I had a
great movie and I've tested it enough if
no one has anything negative to say
about it anymore
which is nonsense because you could do
that until the end of time and it
wouldn't ever happen so by now it's like
if everyone has a different complaint
about the movie then I know I have a
good movie it just has to be a different
complaint from everyone if that person
hates the movie for that reason of that
movie that guy hates that actor in and
that guy hates the score that good
that's okay as long as it's not twenty
five people hating the same actor or the
same score or same whatever you just
want that kind of to spread the
criticism and to dissolve themself but
there was a learning process to arrive
there that you'll never have a
completely positive feedback to anything
we're going back to the quote that I
opened the question with can you think
of any calculated risk that you've taken
no sense your time you know you came out
here you went to AFI any calculated risk
knowing that you you do think things and
I relate to that school thought it's not
a criticism believe me I'm very much in
that same camp but when you overthink
and you want to make sure you plan
things
can you think of any time were you
because I just heard a quote in a
documentary that I saw and the guy said
you know directors are the reckless
people that's a lot of it's interesting
because the reckless isn't necessarily a
bad thing it can actually I just had a
conversation with the director friend of
mine where we were both saying a
variation of that which was directors
are arrogant people because we assume
that we have something to say to the
world that is worth having millions
pumped into it we have a message for the
world that will be so valuable to the
world that someone should give us five
million dollars so that we can tell it
that's that's delusional if you think
about it that it's like a crazy crazy
mindset and yet directors have that I
don't know where it's coming from or why
people accept it or what it is but we
both were in agreement that we're kind
of off that way or that that the idea is
kind of you have to believe in your own
abilities or how special you are or your
ideas or something to to a degree that
is not normal I think and that's not the
same as self-confidence because I don't
think I'm a very self-confident person
definitely not an extrovert another
director personality necessarily itself
but there's something where an idea
drives you it doesn't let you sleep and
just grabs you and wants to be hurt so
now and then you become the vehicle of
that idea and maybe that is what gives
you the impetus to say like it's not
just me thinking that I'm a genius and I
can tell the story it's like the story
wants to be told and it doesn't leave me
alone so I'll have to do that that's
more my experience all right so keeping
in the same vein what if someone told
Elon Musk
you know these ideas that you're having
about this car and some of this you know
and to just you pipe down just just why
don't you go work for a manufacturer
well I don't think it would do any harm
I had had successes I started dangerous
is when it's your first step into
unknown territory
and you know that unknown temperature
it's something you've never done and
you're coming out of your shell and
you're out of your comfort zone and then
that person whoever that person is comes
up and say why don't you do a B and C
status dangerous then people listen to
it because there has to be failure in
the beginning right and there has to be
that's why film school is maybe one of
the big passes I think student king said
that in the book that he wrote about
film making that he said to one
advantage she can see in film schools is
that you can call yourself a filmmaker
like no one can laugh at you and you
have the space and room to fail and I
wish I had seen that in film school
because I was so tense in film school it
all felt like as if you can win
film school you know field school
shouldn't be there to be won for you to
be the most talented in your class and
to show the world and show Hollywood it
should really be and I think they're
doing good job trying to protect it as
much as possible it should be a time
where you are allowed to try stuff and
fail and see what doesn't work said that
edison quote where he said he funny
about 900 methods to not invent a light
bulb and you know before he found the
one that actually worked
what's the same there yeah and so I
think that the ELA mask would probably
be fine I won't be too worried about in
Alaska this one
you